[Music]
oh my god did you see that clip of uh
paris hilton i was watching
your mindset
oh my god i did a little video on that
just like off the cuff because i just
had to throw my two cents out there i
was blown away
what a shoehorn thing yeah cause i
bought mine with moon pay and then i
thought you had to do moon pay and you
bought it you also have an ape right yes
i have also aped in i've also i had i
bought an ape
these sunglasses they have the funny
sunglasses on it because my daughter and
i i own an eight i also have an ape this
[ __ ] said
i like this one because i think i have
the same shirt and my daughter has the
same glasses and i wear those glasses
quarter million dollars too that he pay
for it that's kind of the funniest part
honestly paid
i guess yeah he definitely did not pay
yeah i guess not
breaking this is funny justin bieber has
purchased uh this board ape for 500 oh
yeah i'm sure he spent his own 500 east
on that
i'm sure i mean he like uh what who do
you think bought it for him bro that was
definitely a brand deal and it's
structured so like yeah it looks like he
paid for it
but that like
guaranteed he like got a fee to promote
it and or like to use his name and then
they like what's funny is that he way
overpaid i know it makes me think it's
actually him
no like logging on and be like i gotta
get involved in this and just like
buying one for way too much
that would yeah i mean i wish i would
almost wish that were true but we know
come on dude yeah if we get bieber we'll
just inflate the price a little bit
yeah
yeah yeah he's like uh i don't know
what's a good price like double yeah
yeah
triple i want to make sure we get this
thing i think i should pay five times
yeah
i don't pay like over a million i don't
know [ __ ] it
what where is the yacht club with all
this money
they should at least have a real one
yeah you know
the
yeah nfts are cool though they're sick
now i'm really glad that all the
celebrities get them
yeah okay so what else did you say in
your video what other examples um i just
brought up like some
i brought up a couple things which i was
just like one kid tried to say
you know he's like oh if jimmy brought
out a 67 classic mustang no one would be
critical of that i'm like yeah because
no one buys a classic mustang hoping
that one day they're gonna drive it on a
road
yeah you know what i mean like it's not
1920s one day you'll be able to use this
to get to the other side of the mountain
yeah yeah yeah it has real value now
yeah
and as you know and it's also mustang
isn't paying him to be like hey check
out this brand new mustang i got paris
you also have a mustang right yeah
although they do do that but
not as blatant as that something was
really just like [ __ ] disgusting
about that clip oh yeah my other
favorite they're flexing these quarter
million dollar pictures too on the just
the general public yeah it's like
morning show [ __ ] i mean i guess he's in
the evening but still like
people are watching this like no bro
that's the [ __ ] you guys are these are
they're holding up this is my ape
this is more than your family makes in
like five years
that was mine here it is in a little
picture frame yeah they hold up an ape
and then they the best part about that
instance is he goes look at my quarter
million dollar picture and then someone
has to flip the sign on and the show
runner has to go
then everyone has to just
oh wow
i like the monkey
didn't paris also say like monkey she
said i had to get the monkey or
something like that i missed that part
i think she did i i'm just surprised
that the whole audience didn't bum rush
that stage and eat them can we pull it
up
yeah just bummed rush and just
ate them alive stolen the picture yeah
jimmy's like doesn't matter it's an nft
marcus sent
sent some tweet from this guy that like
kept all of his nfts in he basically had
one like one and a half million dollars
worth of nfts and one wallet and he
he he fell for a hack he signed his
wallet off on some discord that got
hacked to mint something and all of an
all of his nfts were stolen so he
tweeted and was like look at my
collection is gone like this is like my
net worth
everything is gone and some dude replied
and said hey man technically you can't
use that as your profile picture anymore
because you don't
get [ __ ] oh my god
yeah i i jumped in i know i heard i'm so
happy i taught you what they were you
did you taught me what's up and then i
bought an ape i got an ape too
i did i'm so happy that i taught you
that
i'm so happy that i texted you offline
and told you to buy one ape yep
yep
because paris has really dialed in to
and and they're obviously like close
friends they text all the time yeah this
is definitely a very real conversation
on the show with people and you said you
got a moonpay so i went and i copied you
and did the same thing pause
pause dude
like 50 of america was like what was
that sentence yeah
yeah thousand people and a moon pay and
that yeah
what yeah
slow down hold on rewind who [ __ ] you
get a glossary
it's really cool
i hate it ladies and gentlemen the ape
you know says that she like mr rogers
you did it you got an ape this is your
ape wow how special
[ __ ] you
[Applause]
how did you pick
because you can pick your your your
eight yes i was going through a lot of
them and i was like i want something
that like kind of reminds me of me
but like
this one it's it does
yeah no we believe you [ __ ] man we
definitely believe that's how you feel
about this hell yeah
yeah
keep playing it i think we made like
another version of it where he takes the
hat off and blonde hair comes out
yeah cause you could do whatever you
want
oh yeah i remember that talking about
right yeah
when i watch this it's like [ __ ] you
both
[ __ ] you both i don't have enough
[ __ ] money [ __ ] you both but also
it's like this is supposed to be
entertainment it's just
yeah
yeah they're just fleecing
police thank god that version we're part
of the same people part of the same
community
uh here's my this is my yours
yours is so cool i love the red heart
sunglasses i love the captain house oh
oh jimmy's
yeah that i think that's the most
like ridiculous part of this is
what community what what are you guys
talking about you don't [ __ ] care
about this i hate that they try to put
on that they care about this yeah and
and after i made my video some [ __ ]
tweets at me he's like hey man if you
want to talk more about it i think you'd
really like it i'm like i wouldn't
i wouldn't pay
250 000 to be in a discord and be like
this was a good idea
because in my video i'm like give me a
[ __ ] tangible benefit from one of
these things that's further than it'll
be worth
have you checked out the road map for
any of these oh yeah right yeah yeah
excuse me oh my bad there's a lot of
good stuff on the road maps yeah for
sure the herbalife roadmap is awesome
yes exactly yeah
nice nice shirts
stop
reminding me i've worn these heart
sunglasses because my daughters
just as a joke they have them and as a
joke i put them on so oh that's a
[ __ ] hilarious joke what a reason to
spend a quarter million dollars dude
holy [ __ ] as a joke
our sunglasses on
moon pay
moon day oh my god i love your eggs
striped shirt
i wear them
yeah yeah
got the whole squad laughing with that
and i love yacht rock and to being
breezy so i'm like yeah
that kind of and i like the blue mm-hmm
dude look at this they look like they
could be friends they're buddies
yes
all right in paris we did it we did it
because it's half half million dollars
millions
sitting right there look at their
friends
yeah look at their friends
it's like life-changing amounts of money
give that away to the crowd change their
lives forever look at their friends
dude
look they can be friends look at it
they're kissing look at
a quarter million dollars and a quarter
million dollars
and look at this is a new house
and they're kissing and there could be
friends
[ __ ] throws
okay let's let's have an example here
this is all your student debt yeah yeah
no it's gonna this is a brand new house
for your parents and for your grandma
and look at their friends are kissing
and look at
yeah yeah
yeah
i can light it on fire because i don't
care no look at that burning man now
oh my god dude
ladies and gentlemen this is what a 500
000 household looks like these two right
here got together
and kissed and made uh oh and he pulls
out a smaller ape a baby
this one's worth a hundred thousand
we got a 600 000 family
[ __ ] you both
and you know the craziest thing is
off this episode i'm making that amount
of money too oh i'm promoting this to
you i'm i could buy another one of these
and do the same thing tomorrow because
what i did
what i did
a purple shirt on because i like to wear
purple shirts and all four of them kiss
mm-hmm they're a family
just like your family look it just like
your family [ __ ] you both we'll probably
never get on fallon and that's okay
you